I learned that there was going to be
like this international student for
liberty conference and when I saw the
people who were being here like Edward
Snowden Ron Paul you mean park like I
was just like really excited since these
are all like individuals that I admire
and like their ideals are really
something that like resonate with me I
had a bunch of friends the new from like
tumblr and stuff like that and they
always talked about I suppose seeing how
much of a great time it was so it was
just something that I want to experience
I came here to put in the conference so
that they can be exposed to mold better
and materials and see and hear about
what our friends are doing in addressing
everybody other from other parts of the
world what drove me to Joe Giudice
velocities year with these amazing
speakers the subjects are better than
last year I think the most interesting
thing that I saw here at is LLC was
getting to see Edward Snowden speak to
the young libertarians here that was
something that was incredibly moving and
inspirational for me I went to a
breakout session about on using rhetoric
to convince other people of your ideas
without coming off as a crazy person
last night I really enjoyed hearing ron
paul speaks so far i've been going you
know seen a lot of the tables been able
to meet a lot of interesting people and
hopefully i'll be able to go to a lot of
the talks this afternoon Justin peloton
speech it was very inspiring last night
it got huge amounts of applause and
everything and just really struck a
chord with everyone well I'll say the
most interesting the most interesting
I've seen this year is the is the
diversity of the parts pondered
conference so we see a lot of people
from from Latin America from Asia from
Africa and this door shows the global
feel that's not all about your house I
really enjoy seeing people from
different organizations and kind of
seeing really how much the Liberty
movement can be incorporated into a lot
of different facets of life not just
politics or economics well I for a long
time considered myself a conservative
and so I I didn't really feel like it
was answering all the questions that I
had when it came to politics and I
learned about the Liberty movement at
another conference
so really drew me in especially on
social issues it was something that
really balanced it out for me well I
just I was definitely a hard Republican
i campaigned for Mitt Romney a bag in
2012 and then I realized that the things
I disagreed with in the Republican Party
was what the Libertarians agree with so
that was kind of how I ended up here
young people are more libertarian now
than ever though young Africans accepts
you know that I say limits to what the
government can do you know regulate in
your life and I get together to
advancing the cause of Liberty